to me the song one is where i first
started to get to know you guys because
of the video and all that kind of stuff
and
the thought of a guy locked
in his body i mean the guy has no senses
where did this song first of all how do
you start writing a song about all this
my brother uh older brother dave who was
he also played in a band
uh played drums he uh i don't know he
told me a story about
i guess some some he was uh
whatever reading a book and which was
johnny got his gun telling me about this
guy who yeah he was like a prisoner in
his own body
and i related to that because i felt
that
not that i couldn't speak or or hear
or use my limbs but for some reason i
connected with that like being stuck in
your own
skin and how uncomfortable that can feel
and that would be like the
ultimate hell where you can't
communicate to
anybody so the song is about a guy who's
trapped inside his own body he has no
arms he has no legs he can't taste he
can't see he can't smell
or talk and in a way you felt like that
right
because if you you had a miserable
childhood when i read about your
childhood i think
i don't even know how you survived that
well uh and and the
the crazy thing is you know i i grew up
thinking that it was just normal
and i think i'm not you thought your
childhood was normal yeah because how
would you know
otherwise exactly your father left
when uh you were what 16 13 yeah
he leaves and you never hear from the
guy again right i mean pretty much he
didn't support the family
he did not right and your mom
she died shortly thereafter of cancer
right yeah a few years later
so you were basically orphaned yeah so
that's why when we hear this song
one we're not just talking about a guy
who's had his limbs cut off
and had his senses all you know and he's
locked inside his head
it's very much you who had you know
you were cut off from the rest of the
world in a sense and very alone you're
the guy
with his limbs cut off wow all right now
play that song and don't cry
have you ever cried do i owe you for
this therapy session do you
did you cry when you wrote this song
because sometimes when i hear it i'm
almost on the verge of tears i really am
that's great that's great i did not
now i might this is thanks song
done live in our little studio right now
[Music]
[Music]
more
[Music]
[Music]
i can't remember anything
i can't tell if this is true or a dream
deep down inside i feel
oh please
[Music]
back in the room it's much too real
[Music]
praise god
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
oh please god help me
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
laughing
[Music]
so
foreign
so
oh
you